hey I'm Kevin Bacon here on BuzzFeed and
going to do a little quiz about I guess
it's about me it's the law that states
that anyone in Hollywood can be linked
to Kevin Bacon it's six steps or less
although turns out that so many famous
actors are a mere two degrees of
separation in honor of Kevin's new
horror movie should have left we're
putting him to the test to see if he
knows how he's connected to his fellow
horror movie actors this sounds really
really hard each question links Kevin
Bacon to another a horror movie start
it's up to you to figure out if he
starred in a movie with that actor or
which of his former co-star starred in a
movie with that actor so let's see which
of these former Kevin Bacon co-stars
starred in a movie with Midsummer's
Florence Pugh Meryl Streep or Viola
Davis or Kevin Bacon himself
I think it's Meryl Streep correct Kevin
Bacon started the river wild with Meryl
Streep who starred in Little Women
that's right in Florence Butte a ka a
vacant number of two all right now I'm
cooking with gas which one of these
former Kevin Bacon co-star starred in a
movie with Halloween's Jamie Lee Curtis
was a Brad Pitt was it Benedict
Cumberbatch or was it Kevin Bacon
himself I'm gonna say Benedict
Cumberbatch wrong Oh Kevin Bacon and
Jamie Lee Curtis started cui's logic
Gattaca sorry sorry Jamie Lee I don't
know why I forgot that which of these
former Kevin Bacon co-star started a
movie with get outs Daniel Kaluga
was it Forrest Whitaker or Steve Carell
or me I don't think it was me I'm just
gonna go Corral oh man
wrong wrong Kevin Bacon starred in the
air ivory the forest whitaker who
started black panther worth daniel
kahlúa and baked a bacon as a number of
- ah yeah of course I'm terrible at this
game
which of these former Kevin Bacon
co-stars started to move thee with
hereditary Toni Collette Emma Stone
Julianne Moore for me I don't think I
was in a movement with Toni I was in a
movie with
and miss stone maybe she was in oh I'm
just gonna go with that wrong Kevin
Bacon starting his crazy stupid love
with Julianne Moore we started the hours
with Toni Collette a k bacon as a number
of - I was close though
well I wasn't even close really which of
these former Kevin Bacon co-stars
starred in a movie with carries [ __ ]
Spacek was it Mary Steenburgen Kyra
Sedgwick or Kevin Bacon himself Oh me
wrong Kevin Bacon started an ending
online with Mary Steenburgen who starred
in Four Christmases with [ __ ] Spacek a
K bacon is a number of - well I wasn't a
movie with Cissy by the way yeah it was
that was it yeah we were rejected which
these former Kevin Bacon co-star started
in a movie with it chapter two's Jessica
Chastain's a Jennifer Lawrence
Lana Condor or may I was not in a movie
with Jessica Chastain I think I'm gonna
go Lana Kandra wrong Kevin Bacon starred
in x-men first class but Jennifer
Lawrence who started Dark Phoenix with
Jessica Chastain a.k.a
a bacon number of two I hope everybody
out there is doing better than me which
these former Kevin Bacon co-star starred
in the movie with I know what you did
last summer
Sarah Michelle Gellar Kevin Jones Kevin
Costner for Kevin Bacon himself this is
the cabin round I guess I'm gonna say
Kevin Jonas wrong Kevin Bacon and Sarah
Michelle Gellar start in the air I
breathe together oh oh yeah that's right
of course we did which of these former
Kevin Bacon co-stars starred in a movie
with us is Lupita you know I'm gonna say
laurence fishburne wrong Kevin Bacon
started know who came with Laura Dern
who starred in Star Wars the last Jedi
with Lupita Nyong'o
a.k.a bacon number of - I'm really doing
badly here which of these former Kevin
Bacon co-star starred in a movie with
the Shining's Jack Nichols Tom Hanks
alfre woodard or may I picked me correct
Kevin Bacon a Jack Nicholson starred in
a few good men together
I only Kevin Bacon should be able to
pass this well I got two out of nine
right so that's kind before showing I
heard about the six degrees of Kevin
Bacon sometime in the I think it was the
late 90s and people just started coming
up to me and saying I was playing a game
I was playing a game at me heard about
the game and I really thought it was a
joke at my expense I thought the idea
was can you believe that a lightweight
like this could be connected to you know
Laurence Olivier but I really think that
if you take me out of it the actual
concept is to me sort of a beautiful one
because if it's really not about me it's
really about the connectivity of people
that's what we look for all the time is
ways to connect with people please check
out you should have left which is a
movie that I'm actually in so I would
say zero degrees which is on demand
everywhere on June 18th hope you dig it